Hey, Kilian. Hey, Hendrik. Du hast aber eine komische Stimme heute. Ja, ein bisschen erkältet.
Nein, hallo liebe akronomisierbare Zuhörer. Willkommen bei Folge... Oh Gott, ich hab gar nicht mitgezählt.
26. 26, oder? Bin ich nicht verhalten, weiß ich nicht.
Du brauchst deine Stimme gar nicht weiterverstellen.
Wie ihr wahrscheinlich euch von der letzten Folge, wo wir das angekündigt haben, erinnern könnt,
ist Kian leider zur Zeit nicht zur Verfügung.
Er hat seine Seele nämlich an Apple verkauft zumindest für ein halbes Jahr,
der ja da ein Praktikum in Cupertino macht.
Und währenddessen lade ich mir hier interessante Gäste in mein kleines Wohnzimmerstudio ein.
Und diesmal habe ich mir ausgesucht einen guten Freund von mir, Henrik Skupin.
Und wir haben uns kennengelernt bei dem Rust Meetup, was ich angefangen habe zu organisieren, wobei er mir dann später sehr mitgeholfen hat.
Hallo Henrik, willkommen.
Hey Henrik, sehr schön bei dir in meinem Podcast zu sein.
Na, ist gemütlich hier an diesem Kopfhörer.
Ja, das klingt ganz angenehm.
Du hast eine ziemlich coole Geschichte, denn du arbeitest bei Mozilla.
Genau.
Wie bist du denn dazu gekommen?
Lange Geschichte, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt so viel Zeit.
Ne, ich mache es ganz kurz.
Arbeiten für Mozilla
tue ich eigentlich schon seit 2009.
Bereich
Testautomatisierung, QA,
wo ich eingestiegen bin.
Und ja, bin derzeit
eigentlich die ganze Jahre damit
beschäftigt, halt Testframeworks
zu entwickeln, Fehler zu
beseitigen, etc.
Testframeworks entwickeln heißt, du hast an welchen
Projekten konkret gearbeitet?
An vielen Projekten.
damals angefangen hat es mit
Mosmill, war das erste Testframework
eher für den Bereich QA
gewesen, Entwickler haben ja
ihre eigenen Testframeworks
und wir mussten halt
Tests automatisieren, die halt mit diesen
Frameworks nicht funktionierten, deswegen
gab es dann das
Mosmill-Projekt, wo wir dann
UI-Tests
geschrieben haben, Update-Tests
für Firefox etc.
Das lief ein paar Jahre.
Das waren richtige Tests, die Firefox selbst getestet haben?
Das waren richtig Tests, die Firefox-Teste getan. Ganz richtig, genau.
Und das lief ein paar Jahre, bis dann wir angefangen haben, das Firefox OS-Projekt zu starten.
Also für das Mobiltelefon, die OS-Software.
Und da brauchten wir halt ein neues Framework.
Das heißt, dann fing es an mit Marionette.
Und das war einfach notwendig gewesen,
Da wir schon sehr zeitig im Boot-Prozess auch schon die Tests ausführen mussten,
das war halt mit allen anderen Test-Frame-Mocks nicht machbar gewesen.
Und da bin ich halt mit eingestiegen, dann etwas später in Marinette.
Und dieses Framework quasi wird jetzt auch weiterverwendet für die Web-Treiber-Spezifikationen, für die Umsetzung.
Das heißt, über das W3C arbeiten wir, unser Team mit den anderen Browser-Herstellern, an einer Spezifikation,
die es ermöglicht, den Browser fernzusteuern für Testautomatisierung.
Das heißt, es sind Schnittstellen vorgegeben, Kommandos, wo man halt eine neue Webseite laden kann, Elemente sich holen kann, mit Elementen interagieren kann.
Das ist Webdriver?
Das wäre Webdriver, genau. Und da hat jeder Browser entsprechend eine eigene Umsetzung.
Bei uns wäre es quasi der Gecko-Treiber, der mit Firefox genutzt werden kann in Beziehung mit Selenium,
was die meisten Tester einfach dann verwenden, um halt ihre Webseiten im Firefox, Chrome, Safari zu testen.
Das heißt, jemand, der seine Webseite testet, benutzt Selenium, um darin seine UI-Tests zu beschreiben?
Selenium wäre in dem Fall eines der bekanntesten.
Als Beispiel benutzt du die Webdriver-Schnittstelle, um beliebige Browser parallel eventuell anzusteuern,
um darin die unterschiedlichen Tests zu fahren.
Bei Firefox heißt das Gecko-Driver, bei Chrome wäre das, glaube ich, Chrome-Driver.
Genau. Und an dieser Schnittstelle arbeitest du mit quasi?
Also wir arbeiten mit an der Spezifikation.
Wir hatten gerade letzte Woche BodyDPEC gewesen vom B3C, also ein Treffen, wo unsere Arbeitsgruppe sie auch getroffen hat
und wir an der weiteren Spezifikationen gearbeitet haben, neue Features mit reinzubringen.
Und die werden quasi jetzt auch weiterhin mit umgesetzt.
Und Marionette ist was in diesem Umfeld?
Gute Frage. Wir haben jetzt nur vom Gecko-Treiber gesprochen.
Mit Marinette an sich hatten wir, wie ich schon vorhin erwähnt hatte, für Firefox OS geschrieben,
sodass wir das brauchten mit der Einschränkung, dass das halt ein eigenes Socket-Protokoll implementiert,
was nicht kompatibel ist mit der Webtreiberschnittstelle.
Das heißt, hier brauchten wir einfach noch ein Proxy und das ist quasi der Gecko-Treiber zwischen Firefox.
Also Marinette an sich selbst ist im Firefox mit implementiert, ist andeutig mit drin, kann auch benutzt werden.
Ach, und Gecko-Driver ist dann quasi der Aufsatz, der Marinette nach außen das Interface gibt, das kompatibel ist zu Web-Driver.
Richtig, genau.
Ah, cool.
Es ist ein HTTP-Server,
den man dann quasi Kommando schicken kann
mit
Chasing-Data
und die dann quasi
ins Manion-Protokoll umgemandet werden
und dann in Firefox
ausgeführt werden und dann kommen entsprechend
die Antworten dann zurück.
Jetzt, wir benutzen
das auch auf Arbeit, um unsere
Web-Anwendung darin zu testen und
jetzt
fragt man sich manchmal, ja, du kannst ja eigentlich
in so einer Webseite, du hast da drin JavaScript,
du kannst da im Websocket
reinsprechen, du kannst ja mit dir eigentlich fast alles
machen. Das heißt, ich könnte
jetzt ein Stückchen Code in meiner Webseite platzieren,
die die komplett fernsteuerbar macht
und Events auslöst. Wozu brauche ich dann noch
konkret sowas wie Webdriver? Was kann der
mehr, als was ich eventuell im Browser
mit
Browser-nativen Technologien machen könnte?
Na gut, du möchtest ja die Tests von außerhalb
starten und nicht innerhalb.
Das heißt,
du hast halt
deine Test-Suite.
Ich kenne jetzt komplett die anderen Test-Suiten nicht,
die ihr verwendet in dem Sinn,
wie die implementiert sind, ob die dann innerhalb von Browser
ausgeführt werden, wie auch immer.
Aber über Web-Treiber
hast du halt eine externe Test-Suite
mit den ganzen
UI-Tests, die du ausführen lassen möchtest
und
die kannst du quasi
über Gecko-Treiber und Selenium
dann steuern. Man kann damit ja
wahrscheinlich auf ein paar APIs mehr zugreifen
oder ein paar Sachen mehr machen, die man über die normale Browser-native API aus JavaScript aus
wahrscheinlich sogar auch aus Sicherheitsgründen nicht machen kann.
Man kann wahrscheinlich gewisse...
Also wir haben auf alle Fälle erstmal dann diese normalen Kommandos,
wie ich vorhin schon meinte, mit Webseite laden, Elemente sich beziehen über ID,
Tagname, Classname, CSS, Selector und so weiter,
dass du halt einen Klick synthetisieren kannst, Keypresses zum Beispiel,
Und dann für spezielle Sachen, die mehr Setup brauchen zum Beispiel,
oder du mehr Internals ansprechen musst, gibt es halt einen Befehl, um Skripte auszuführen.
Das heißt, du bastelst dir einen JavaScript-Code zusammen, den du quasi an den Browser schickst,
wo du die Sachen ausführen lassen kannst.
Und dann kannst du wirklich machen, was du wirklich möchtest.
Genau. Und der Vorteil von dem Ganzen ist auch mit Selenium an sich, bietet es ja die Möglichkeit, die Tests lokal ausführen zu lassen oder remote, auch per Grid, in dem Sinne, was jetzt gerade in Arbeit ist, was quasi jetzt implementiert, dass du quasi sagen kannst, ich möchte, schick es einfach raus, die Tests, soll auf Firefox, Chrome und so weiter getestet werden und das Grid entscheidet selber, wo die Tests ablaufen und du bekommst am Ende halt einfach die Ergebnisse.
Das ist dann eine Software-as-a-Service-Cloud-Anwendung quasi,
die mir irgendwo einen Browser startet,
um dann die Anwendung zu testen.
Also ähnlich wie Source Labs in dem Sinne.
Ah ja.
Genau.
Cool.
Ja, da hast du ja einiges zu tun.
Das machst du,
du arbeitest hier in Dresden
dann so als von zu Hause aus quasi.
Das ist von zu Hause aus, genau.
Ja, cool.
Wie ist es so bei Mozilla zu arbeiten?
Genial.
Also ich habe meinen Traumjob gefunden.
Da wird sich momentan im nächsten Zeitraum auch nichts ändern daran.
Bei Mozilla selbst bin ich jetzt schon seit zehn Jahren als Angestellter tätig.
Und jedes Jahr kommen halt neue Projekte hinzu.
Es ist ja nicht nur das Projekt, an dem ich arbeite.
Dann wird man halt in andere Teilprojekte mit reingeworfen, an denen man temporär mitarbeitet.
Und es macht einfach wahnsinnig Spaß.
Das ist herausfordernd.
Das Wichtige ist auch,
das war halt eine Umstellung für mich
am Anfang auch mit, dass halt
das Team komplett verteilt ist auf der ganzen Welt.
Du bist der Einzige hier in Dresden.
Ich bin das Einzige in Dresden, genau.
In Deutschland
sind wir schon mehr.
Berlin ist unser
Office von Deutschland.
Dort war ich auch schon mal kurz zu Besuch
zu einem Rust Meetup. Das ist ein ziemlich cooles Büro.
Das ist schick.
Jetzt sogar bei der neuen Etage.
in ein paar Wochen.
Okay, ich sehe, ich muss nochmal hin.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und wo waren wir hier stehen geblieben jetzt?
Es war eine Umstellung,
weil verteilt... Umstellung, richtig, genau.
Das ganze Team ist halt
verteilt auf der ganzen Welt.
Meine Kollegen aus dem jetzigen
Team sitzen in
England, also in London,
Amerika, Kanada,
haben wir auch noch eigentlich
in vielen Ländern, Office ist auch in vielen
Ländern und Hauptstandort
ist Mountain View,
also auch in der Nähe, wo jetzt Kilian
in dem Sinne auch ist.
Schön, grüß übrigens Kilian.
Wir vermissen dich hier.
Allerdings.
Vorher, wie du,
man sitzt halt im Büro, arbeitet
mit den Kollegen zusammen, die Kollegen sind vor Ort,
man kann entsprechend die Sachen klären,
ist in dem Sinne was anderes, man arbeitet
erstmal so in dem Sinne räumlich
für sich allein und
muss sich halt quasi auf
Kommunikationsmittel wie IRC,
Videochats, in dem Sinne
zurückgreifen, um halt mit den Kollegen
sprechen zu können.
Ja, das ist vor allem interessant,
wenn du derjenige bist, der im weitesten
östlich wohnt, weil dann hast du wahrscheinlich
Meetings, die teilweise noch recht spät sein können, oder?
Das war gerade zu Beginn,
als ich angefangen habe,
in der QA-Abteilung sehr kompliziert.
Da Großteil
von dem ganzen Team in Mountain View,
das war damals das einzige Office,
was wir hatten in Mountain View,
jetzt gibt es ja auch in San Francisco
noch ein größeres Office
da hast du ja die neun Stunden
Zeitdifferenz
und Meetings fanden da
generell eigentlich immer nach dem Mittag statt
das heißt um zwei, um drei
das heißt, wenn du halt hochrechnest
hast du halt abends um zehn, um elf
immer noch ein Meeting und das war jede Woche
eins bis zwei Mal gewesen
Das ist bei mir recht ähnlich, wir haben Kollegen
auch in Kalifornien
und
mit einem der Teams da drüben arbeiten wir auch
hier von Dresden aus zusammen,
was dazu führt, dass entweder wir
Meetings mit denen, wenn die
gerade mit Arbeit anfangen, so gegen
17, 18 Uhr haben, oder
wie es jetzt bei einem meiner Kollegen
von da drüben ist,
dass die ihre
Arbeitsstunden nach vorne ziehen.
Das ist glücklicherweise der eine, mit dem ich am meisten zu tun habe,
recht war Frühaufsteher
und steht jetzt jeden Tag um 5 auf
und hat jetzt offiziell angekündigt, dass er seine
Arbeitszeiten irgendwie weiter nach vorne
zieht, um mehr mit den deutschen Kollegen zusammenarbeiten
zu können. Das ist ganz schön krass. Also der steht uns
trotzdem erst frühestens ab 15
Uhr zu Gesprächen
zur Verfügung. Das ist eine sehr
interessante Art und Weise, zusammenzuarbeiten.
Wir hatten,
wir haben ja auch dann entsprechend noch ein Office
in Neuseeland und
das heißt, wenn du dann alles koordinieren möchtest
mit einem größeren Team, wenn halt
Leute aus dem Team in Neuseeland,
in Europa, in Amerika sitzen,
dann wird es wirklich schwierig.
Man könnte sich ja vorstellen,
Wenn jetzt das Team wirklich gut zusammenarbeitet, dann könntest du so einen fließenden Übergang zwischen den einzelnen Standorten machen und sagen, die einen hier in Neuseeland fangen das Projekt an und die in Europa, wenn die anderen ins Bett gehen, machen fließend weiter und geben dann ab an die Leute in den USA. Aber so richtig funktionieren tut das nicht, oder?
Also jeder hat natürlich dann seinen Bereich, an dem er arbeitet.
Also gerade, wenn wir jetzt über den Bereich Entwicklung sprechen,
wie es im Design etc. abläuft, kann ich jetzt wenig dazu sagen.
Jeder hat seine Bugs, an denen er arbeitet, was natürlich hilfreich ist.
Beim Ganzen ist, du machst deine Änderungen, lädst sie hoch,
fragst nach Review und hast in dem Sinne halt zeitversetzt
dein Review später bekommen, wenn du wieder aufwachst.
Das heißt, du weißt genau, okay, die und die Sachen sind jetzt halt noch zu machen.
Das nächste Mal kannst du machen,
bis der andere wieder online kommt.
Wenn es klappt.
Wenn du Fragen hast, Probleme da sind,
dann musst du natürlich warten.
Du hast noch...
Aber im Endeffekt finde ich
das eine super Lösung auch mit,
weil du einfach halt
in verschiedenen Zeitzonen deine Kollegen hast
und auf jeden Fall großteils immer jemanden hast,
mit dem du sprechen kannst.
Aber so richtig die Zusammenarbeit abgeben,
kannst du ja nicht...
Also die Arbeit selber, an der du gerade arbeitest,
richtig abgeben, wird wahrscheinlich nie funktionieren, weil du müsstest
quasi deinen gesamten Zustand, dein gesamtes Gehirn
müsstest du weiterschicken. Du kannst jetzt nicht,
das dauert ja teilweise
eine halbe Stunde jeden Morgen, bis ich mich daran erinnert
habe, was ich am Vorabend gemacht habe und
da jetzt jemand anderen diese Information zu übergeben,
wo jetzt weiterzuarbeiten wäre, geht
glaube ich nicht so gut.
Du hast noch ein anderes Projekt
hier in Dresden am Start und zwar
parallel zu dem Rust Meetup, was wir
mittlerweile
zweimonatig machen.
Hast du auch noch ein Mozilla-Meetup am Start?
Genau.
Was machst du denn da?
Ja, hier möchte ich einfach versuchen, ein bisschen Leute auch mit zu animieren im Bereich Dresden,
die vielleicht Interesse haben, mehr über Mozilla zu erfahren, an was wir arbeiten, wie wir arbeiten,
vielleicht selbst sogar mit programmieren möchten, an einzelnen Bugs, die Kenntnisse erweitern.
Das sind eigentlich so die Hauptbestandteile, warum ich als Meetup entsprechend auch mit organisiere.
Was wir eigentlich in Abwechslung in dem Sinne mit Rast-Meetup auch immer machen.
Und das Gute ist halt, man kann es wunderbar kombinieren in dem Sinne auch mit.
Es ist praktisch, dass die Sprache auch von Mozilla erfunden wurde.
Genau.
Du hast einmal einen sehr interessanten Vortrag über das Bildsystem von euch geredet.
Das ist schon mal eine ziemlich interessante Angelegenheit gewesen.
möchte ich jetzt gar nicht zu weit ausholen, aber es ist
erstaunlich, wie gut es bei euch zu funktionieren
scheint mit
ich lade mir fertig gebaute
Artefakte einfach aus dem Netz runter, weil
das CI-System, das im Hintergrund
eh immer baut und ich bei mir lokal
wirklich nur das Minimalste kompilieren muss,
um ein laufendes Firefox
um einen fertigen
Firefox zum Laufen zu bringen.
Bis hin zu eurem
Bug-Tracking-System, was auch
ziemlich krass ist.
oder die Tatsache, dass ihr in der Lage seid,
Mac-Builds komplett auf Linux-Kisten cross-zukompilieren.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe,
sind die ganzen Firefox-Binaries für Mac
alle gar nicht auf Mac gebaut worden.
Genau, richtig.
Das läuft sogar seit, lass mich raten,
das war seit ca. einem halben Jahr,
müsste es so funktionieren.
Genau, abgefahren.
Und das letzte Meetup, was du gemacht hast,
war zum Thema Contributing zu Firefox.
Genau.
Da konnte ich leider nicht daran teilnehmen.
Könntest du das nochmal für mich wiederholen?
Schade.
Ja, das war jetzt
das allererste Meetup, was ich hier
quasi in Dresden gemacht habe,
wo es euch darum ging,
selbst an einem
Bug mitzuarbeiten oder ein Problem
oder ein neues Feature zu implementieren.
Bereich
natürlich Automatisierung.
Und da waren ein paar Leute
auch mit da gewesen und das Gute war,
ein Projekt, was wir uns ausgesucht haben,
MOS Download, was verwendet werden kann
als ein CLI-Kommando,
mit dem man ganz einfach
Firefox-Builds herunterladen kann.
MOS Download.
Genau. Das heißt,
einfache Kommandozeile mit ein paar Optionen.
Kann man sich in Release, in Beta-Build,
Candidate-Builds, Nightly-Builds,
was immer man möchte, entsprechend herunterladen.
Und da
ein anmessend
hatte Interesse daran und haben wir
hier ein neues Feature implementiert,
womit man
die Defetition Builds jetzt auch herunterladen
kann, die ja auch schon eigentlich eine Weile
releasen werden von uns.
Bevor die ersten
Beta Builds für die neue Version
freigegeben werden. Das heißt,
MOS Download kann ich mehr... Genau,
ist auf PyPI entsprechend
herunterladbar. Ah, ist also in Python geschrieben.
Ist in Python geschrieben. Ihr habt sowieso
ein Großteil eurer Software ist
in... Also Firefox selber ist natürlich
größtenteils C++.
C, C++ und jetzt auch
Und ein Großteil von der UI ist in JavaScript geschrieben, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
Aber viel von eurer Backend-Software ist größtenteils eigentlich sogar Python. Kann das sein?
Python wird hauptsächlich für das Bildsystem und für Testautomalisierung eingesetzt.
Ah ja, stimmt. Ihr habt dieses krasse Mach-Bildsystem, richtig?
Ja, genau.
Kannst du darüber ein bisschen was erzählen?
Sehr gerne.
Das heißt Mach, Anlehnung auf Make, dem deutschen Wort Mach,
ist quasi wirklich eine eierlegende Wollmichsau,
die verschiedene Kommandos implementiert,
wieder Sub-Kommandos implementiert, um halt das Bildsystem vorzubereiten.
Also für diejenigen, die jetzt neu anfangen oder einsteigen zum Contributing,
die selbst Code mit beisteuern möchten,
sich das Repository, was ein Monorepository ist,
entsprechend untergeladen haben.
Bietet Mach allein schon Befehle wie Bootstrap,
wo wirklich alle Dependencies installiert werden,
Mercure konfiguriert wird,
sodass es halt ideal genutzt werden kann.
Das heißt, hier fängt man an,
schreibt seinen Code,
kann dann entsprechend den Code kompilieren mit Mach-Bild,
je nachdem welches
Machtbild, genau,
je nachdem, ob man
das
in Artifact-Bild haben möchte
oder ein komplettes Bild,
was du vorhin schon sagtest, mit Herunterladen von den
fertigen Bilds wäre quasi so ein Artifact-Bild.
Damals war ein
komplettes Bild, was circa eine
Stunde dauert zu kompilieren, selbst auf modernen
Rechnern, lohnt sich einfach
jetzt nicht wirklich für die Änderung
in der Oberfläche, das heißt, Artifact-Bilds
erlauben ist, hier ein Build zu bekommen
innerhalb von drei Minuten.
Abgefahren.
Das heißt, Mach ist ja komplett in Python
geschrieben, das heißt, ich muss mir wahrscheinlich dann, wenn ich
mir ein Firefox bauen möchte, eigentlich
nur das Monorepository von euch
ziehen und dann am Anfang wahrscheinlich
einmal Mach sagen, es wird alles eingerichtet
und im Idealfall kriege ich sogar schon
bereits für meine Plattform die aktuellsten Builds
einfach runtergeladen. Also es sind zwei
Kommandos. Mach Bootstrap
bereit dir komplett den ganzen
Bereich vor und
mit Mach Build kannst du dir entsprechend
das Build generieren. Das müsste man ja fast mal
ausprobieren.
Mache ich nicht jetzt.
Mir kribbelt es gerade schon in den Finger.
Ja, und wie gesagt,
für Installer
generieren, für Testautomatisierung,
da ist alles
entsprechend als Kommando implementiert,
was dann ausgeführt werden kann.
Wir haben ja jetzt nicht nur einen
Testharness,
es sind ja wirklich
zehn oder mehr verschiedene,
was mach auch alles transparent
implementiert. Das heißt, man muss nicht mal wirklich wissen,
diese Tests werden mit der
Harness ausgeführt. Man hat gesagt,
einfach nur mach Test und gib
den Pfad an und mach
weiß automatisch, mit welcher
Harness diese Tests ausgeführt werden müssen.
Aber es macht dann
generisch? Kann man das auch auf andere Projekte
schmeißen oder ist das sehr spezifisch für das
Mozilla Repository, für das Firefox
Repository konfiguriert?
Kann ich jetzt nicht genau sagen, aber ich denke mal,
es wird schon sehr auf unsere Repository
ausgerichtet sein. Aber ich meine...
Ich denke mal, der Code ist frei verfügbar.
Sicherlich wird es
per Konfiguration angepasst werden können.
Also ich weiß, dass der
Rust-Compiler mit Mach gebaut
wird oder zumindest gebaut wurde.
Und das ist ja ein komplett separates Repository.
Also wird es wahrscheinlich irgendwie
übertragbar sein.
Das ist cool.
Das ist auch was Neues für mich.
Ja, aber eigentlich wollten wir über das Contributing
zu Firefox reden, richtig?
Genau.
Also wie können denn Leute heute zu Firefox oder allgemein, wenn du jetzt darüber redest,
meinst du hauptsächlich zum Contributing zum Browser selber oder habt ihr noch Projekte, zu denen man auch noch mitarbeiten kann?
Ursula als ich, wir sind natürlich sehr bemüht, alle Sachen offen zu behandeln.
dass alle Projekte wirklich offen zugänglich sind,
man überall entsprechend
mithelfen kann, wer möchte.
Geht natürlich nicht hundertprozentig,
aber das ist uns
entsprechend schon wichtig. Das heißt,
es gibt verschiedene Webseiten,
können wir
sicherlich in die Show Notes
reinwerfen, dann nachher
als Einstiegsseiten,
wo man sich
wie in einer Baumstruktur
durchhangeln kann. Ich habe jetzt halt Interesse
in der Lokalisierung oder
Programmierung, was auch immer.
Programmierung, ja, welche Sprache,
wo man dann genau findet,
in welchem Bereich man quasi wirklich
ideal mithelfen kann
oder wo man selbst Interesse halt hat,
sein Wissen zu erweitern.
Ist ja nicht nur so, dass wir halt Leute suchen, die halt
für uns die Bugs beseitigen oder neue Videos
implementieren,
sondern dass natürlich auch dann schon
ein gewisser Stellen mehr da ist,
dass die Leute auch was lernen davon und mitbekommen.
So, ich schreibe hier bloß mal kurz auf
links, dass wir uns das
merken.
Das heißt,
du bist ja wahrscheinlich auch relativ
jung schon da eingestiegen in die Codepace.
Ich habe auch
vor 20 Jahren.
Ich habe
im gleichen Zeitraum auch so als
Schüler schon irgendwie in dem ERC-Channel
von hier
Mosnet mitgelesen und mit ein paar
Leuten unterhalten. Hat mich natürlich damals,
der einzige in meiner Umgebung, der irgendwie
sich für Programmieren interessiert hat,
hab da nicht sonderlich viel Feedback bekommen
und hab dann halt irgendwann gesagt, nee,
mach ich das jetzt erstmal nicht, aber
du bist da eigentlich schon recht gut
eingestiegen dann und gab's
da irgendwie die Möglichkeit, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich bin jetzt
15 oder
bin gerade mit dem Abi fertig
oder möchte jetzt das Programmieren ansteigen, wäre da
so ein Mozilla-Projekt der richtige
Ort?
Für jemanden, der jetzt,
das ist ein großer,
ein Riesenhaufen C++-Codes, der
High-Performance- und Sicherheitsanforderungen
erfüllen muss,
das ist ja erstmal so ein bisschen
einschüchternd. Das kann man da
trotzdem, wenn man bei Mozilla mitarbeiten möchte,
als jemand, der so Einsteiger ist,
findest du das ist, was
man sich tutrauen könnte? Kriegt man da Hilfe
oder wie funktioniert das bei euch?
Genau.
Hier gibt es natürlich dann verschiedene Voraussetzungen,
je nachdem, wie gut deine Kenntnisse in den Bereichen
schon sind, haben
wir verschiedene
Schwierigkeitsgrade
von den Bugs, die wir auch kennzeichnen.
einfach, mittelschwer oder schwer, die man sich auch dann aussuchen kann.
Also über diese Webseite, die ich vor uns meine, wo man hingeleitet wird,
gibt es dann quasi eine Reihe von Bugs, die angezeigt werden.
Man wählt aus, welche Sprache man machen möchte, welche Kenntnisse man hat.
Jetzt redest du aber schon wieder von Bugs.
Aber das ist bei euch, ist das Sprech, ein Bug ist einfach ein Ticket bei euch, richtig?
Ein Bug ist ein Ticket.
Das heißt, alle Arbeiten, die wirklich stattfinden, sind wirklich hart an einem Bug gekoppelt.
Das heißt, bei euch ist wirklich alles ein Bug.
Selbst wenn das heißt, ich aktualisiere mal die Localization
oder ich baue tatsächlich ein neues Feature irgendwo ein,
ist auch ein Bug.
Also alles über ein Bug getrackt.
Weil es alles bei euch in Bugzilla getrackt wird.
Das heißt, ein Bug ist, was ein GitHub-In-Issue wäre
oder einfach so ein Ticket.
Ja, cool.
Also es gibt unterschiedliche Stufen für Einsteiger
und unterschiedliche Schwierigkeitsgrade.
Ist das bei Mozilla, bei dem Haupttrepo auch so ähnlich?
Ich kenne das aus dem Rust-Repository.
gibt es Kennzeichnungen mit Easy und so
Mentoring-Tickets? Gibt es das auch bei
zum Beispiel Firefox oder bei
Gecko-Driver? Genau.
Das heißt, für
die Sachen, wo wir
wirklich dann Leute haben möchten, die
an den Sachen arbeiten, werden
diese Bug-Tickets
entsprechend auch markiert als Mentored.
Das heißt, für diese Bugs gibt es direkt
einen Ansprechpartner, der
natürlich bestmöglich aus dem Team
ist, in dem Bereich
der Bug gefeiert worden ist.
Das heißt, man wird hier wirklich
von Anfang an bis zum Ende
betreut
bei den einfachen Bugs.
Man kann sich vorstellen, am Anfang
schon schwierig, Sachen einzurichten,
dass alles funktioniert, oder
den Code zu finden, anzupassen,
wie führe ich die Tests aus.
Häufig überhaupt das mal zum Bauen zu bekommen.
Zum Bauen, genau. Das funktioniert
dann momentan schon sehr einfach.
Das habt ihr auch mal hingekriegt, ja.
Das heißt, hier das Schwierige ist einfach wirklich
nur der ganze Ablauf.
ist ja nicht nur, dass ich jetzt halt sage,
ich hacke jetzt hier meinen Code rein,
behebe das Problem, es funktioniert lokal.
Wie teste ich es?
Und wie bringe ich es quasi jetzt,
wie lade ich es hoch,
dass quasi der Mentor das reviewen kann.
Das heißt, man arbeitet eigentlich die ganze Zeit
mit jemandem anders zusammen,
der das im Notfall auch selber machen könnte.
Genau.
Ich frage mich immer,
wenn dann so ein Bug-Ticket jetzt
dasteht mit, hier kann jemand
machen, der neu ist,
wir mentern euch. Ich meine, dieses Ticket
hat doch bestimmt auch irgendwie
so ein Ticket
wird ja aufgemacht, weil das wirklich auch gebraucht
wird, was da drin ist.
Funktioniert das bei euch, dass das da nicht einfach irgendwann rumliegt?
Gibt es irgendwie sowas, dass diese Tickets dann irgendwann
geschlossen werden, weil es einfach irgendwann gemacht werden muss,
wenn sich jemand findet? Oder
hat es mir jetzt einfach immer geklappt, dass sich jemand gefunden hat,
der es machen wollte? Also wichtig wäre erstmal
so, dass zu sagen, wir
stellen diese Mentor-Bug-Tickets
nur für die Sachen,
die es wirklich nicht dringend benötigt werden.
Also so nice to half Sachen.
Genau, oder die man irgendwann machen möchte,
was entsprechend schön wäre.
Es kann natürlich immer sein,
dass so ein Bug irgendwann
dann doch benötigt wird.
Das heißt, wenn bis dahin niemand den Bug angefasst hat,
müssen wir ihn quasi
selber einfach machen.
Dann muss man das selber machen.
Aber gerade einfache Sachen.
Sachen, die mit einer Code-Seite
zu ändern sind zum Beispiel,
sind herrlich gerade für Anfänger-Bugs
zum Beispiel.
Dann sollte man sich aber gleich den nächsten Bug
schon rausgesucht haben, sonst ist man ja sofort.
Aber dass man diesen Workflow
entsprechend mitbekommt, wie der funktioniert.
Gerade das
Wie läuft ein Review ab?
Dieses Feedback, was ich bekomme,
muss ich die Änderung einpflegen?
muss ich meinen Patch aktualisieren,
entsprechend wieder zum Review hinschicken.
Bis zum Ende quasi, bis dieser Patch landen kann.
Wie kommuniziert man auf Code Reviews und sowas.
Genau. Also Fragen sind ja auch da.
Man kann es über das Bug-Ticket kommunizieren,
was hilfreich ist, wenn die andere Seite jetzt nicht gerade verfügbar ist.
Oder hauptsächlich das Medium, was wir nutzen, ist IRC.
Also nicht weggegangen?
Nee.
Das ist eigentlich dann das Grundlegende für uns noch für die direkte Synchronik-Kommunikation.
Solche Sachen sind ja auch alles Sachen, die man erst lernt, wenn man wirklich anfängt, an Code mitzuarbeiten.
Also ich kann mir das sehr gut vorstellen, dass es viele Leute gibt, die ein komplettes Informatikstudium abgeschlossen haben
und dann so gewisse, ich nenne es mal Handwerkszeugs, nicht nur wie programmiere ich,
sondern wie kommuniziere ich mit Leuten über Code, wie arbeite ich synchron, asynchron an bestimmten Projekten zusammen, wie organisiere ich Arbeit in solchen Tickets oder Bugs, das ist ja das, was eigentlich so das Softwareentwicklerleben oder den Softwareentwickler zu einem Ausbildungsberuf macht.
Wir haben uns jetzt auch überlegt, wir würden gerne Studenten haben, die bei uns direkt im Team mitarbeiten.
Da habe ich auch überlegt, eigentlich könnte man sich schon mal so ein paar Studententickets oder so hier mentored oder easy Tickets zur Seite legen,
die wir dann speziell taggen, damit sie nicht irgendwie ewig lang in unserem Jira rumliegen und dann irgendwann das Management kommt,
da habt ihr so lauter Tickets, die nicht bearbeitet werden.
aber das ist ja eigentlich ein schöner Einstiegspunkt,
um direkt Leute, die neu sind,
sei es nur einer Firma oder einem Open-Source-Projekt,
direkt einzufangen und zu engagieren.
For a lack of a better German world.
Ich spreche echt zu viel Englisch den ganzen Tag.
Genau.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein ziemlich schönes Konzept, muss ich sagen.
Das funktioniert bei euch schon eine ganze Weile so.
Also über was wir jetzt sprechen, ist wirklich freiwillige Contribution in dem Sinn.
Wir haben jetzt noch andere Bereiche, weil du gerade eben auch anfängst,
über deine Firma oder Studenten entsprechend auch mithaben zu wollen,
die natürlich praktische Erfahrungen auch brauchen neben dem Studium.
Das heißt, bieten natürlich auch an Internships.
Das heißt, hier sind offen die Stellenbewertungen im Netz auch erreichbar.
Das heißt, wer Interesse hat, bei uns entsprechend Praktikum etc.
zu machen, Diplomarbeit,
wie auch immer, ist natürlich auch
machbar.
Wie würde das jetzt aussehen für jemanden,
sagen wir aus Dresden hier,
es gibt ja kein Büro in Dresden,
würde der dich dann zu Hause
besuchen oder wie ist
da der Ablauf? Also in meinem Team wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht sein, dafür sind einfach
dann die Arbeitsbereiche zu klein
für eine Diplomarbeit,
aber andere Teams, die quasi
größere Projekte haben, die sich wirklich dann über
halbes Jahr oder wie lange
das dann entsprechend geht,
hinzieht, die bieten dann
das entsprechend auch an. Das heißt, die
Sachen werden ausgeschrieben und
Leute können sie einfach darauf
bewerben und
dann kommt es normal zum Auswahlverfahren.
Bewerbungsgespräche
und wenn man es schafft, dann kann man quasi
seine Zubumarbeit entsprechend auch bei uns machen.
Und da hat man dann einen Betreuer, der
hoffentlich in der gleichen Zeit so ohne lebt wie man selbst?
Voraussetzung hier ist natürlich
meistens, man arbeitet nicht von zu Hause,
sondern von einem Büro aus.
Das heißt, man muss dann auch wirklich
nach Berlin, Paris, London...
Berlin wäre das Nächste.
Wobei hier auch die Frage ist,
ist jemand aus diesem Team in Berlin?
Wenn nicht, geht es weiter weg.
Also es kann natürlich auch gut sein,
San Francisco.
Es kann sein.
Was natürlich ein Schlechtes wäre.
Das wäre jetzt auch nichts, das Trauer ist.
Genau.
Ah ja, cool.
Was soll ich jetzt als nächstes fragen?
Ansonsten kann ich Konstruieren fortsetzen.
Das heißt, es werden gerade die Internships,
die wir anbieten.
Und dann gibt es noch zwei größere Bereiche
im Bereich Contributing, was
Google Sum of Code erstmal wäre.
Das heißt, hier haben wir
auch eigentlich regelmäßig
sehr viele Projekte, die
da mit eingestellt werden,
an denen
die entsprechend finanziert werden.
Das ist ja dann quasi
nicht weit weg, also eine größere
Variante einfach von diesem Mentoring-Ticket.
Ihr habt schon euch ein Projekt
zurechtgelegt und sitzt dann da
ein Stück hinten drauf. Genau.
Google Samoff Code hat den Vorteil,
dass es irgendwie, dass man so eine Zwischeneinreichung hat.
Da gibt es ja bestimmt noch
manchmal Sachen, die scheitern. Ich war jetzt selber
noch nicht an so einem Projekt beteiligt,
deswegen kann ich keine Details dazu sagen,
aber ich soll sicherlich dann zwischendurch
immer wieder Absprachen geben oder wie weit
ist derjenige gekommen,
um halt Probleme zu erkennen,
die hoffentlich beseitigen zu können,
um dann doch das gewünschte Ziel
entsprechend zu erreichen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das jetzt geht.
Das ist irgendwas, was man in den Sommerferien
schafft.
Ein paar Freunde von mir haben
während des Studiums dann sowas,
also beim VUGES haben auch teilweise mehrmals
bei der gleichen Firma
teilgenommen.
Kann ich leider auch nicht so viel erzählen,
habe ich selber nie gemacht.
Man reicht ja die Projekte ein,
weiß aber auch nicht, ob sie dann quasi nachgenommen werden von Google.
Also die Firmen reichen die Projekte ein?
Genau, die Firmen reichen die Projekte ein,
wo sie denken, oder die sie bei Arbeit haben möchten.
Und wenn sie halt fancy genug klingen,
wichtig genug klingen,
dann bekommt man entsprechend auch dann den Zuschlag dafür halt, genau.
Und es gab auch schon Jahre,
wo wir einfach keine einzige Stelle bekommen haben.
Das sind ja alles Sachen, die dann auch nicht von den Firmen,
sondern tatsächlich von Google bezahlt werden.
Genau. Das ist natürlich auch ein ganz schönes
Prestigeprojekt für die Bude.
Sie einfach mal die Open-Source-Welt
fördern, indem sie Studenten
anstellen, um dann solche Projekte mitzuwachen.
Genau. Ja, das ist krass.
Und das wäre das Zweite.
Und dann gibt es noch Outreachy.
Outreachy.
Schon was davon gehört?
Den Begriff muss man, glaube ich, erklären
für nicht-englisch-sprechende Leute.
Das sind quasi,
es läuft ähnlich ab wie
Google Summer of Code.
ist entsprechend aber nur für Personen zugeschnitten aus unterrepräsentierten Bereichen.
Also Outreach für Outreach.
Also man streckt quasi den Arm aus zu Leuten, die aus unterrepräsentierten Gruppen sind.
um sie halt in den Bereich mit reinzubekommen.
Was leider auch momentan
groß, dass Frauen entsprechend auch mit sind.
Frauenquote ist natürlich schon überall
gering in technischen Bereichen.
Das heißt hier sind...
Unterrepräsentierte Gruppe.
Oder quasi in Asien, Lateinamerika,
dass man da halt wirklich
Leute findet, die wirklich
gut sind,
um die halt wirklich dann entsprechend
an was arbeiten zu lassen auch mit.
Wo sie dann einfach
einen Einstieg in den Bereich
später auch haben und Arbeit finden können.
Und ich muss sagen, wir hatten schon
mehrere erfolgreiche Outreach-Projekte,
auch in meinem Team,
die entsprechend auch nachher
fest eingestellt worden sind.
Ja, das ist cool.
Es ist häufig wahrscheinlich so,
das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass die Leute sich
gesellschaftlich nicht trauen würden,
sich bei einer Firma zu bewerben
und da ist es ja recht competitive,
wenn du dich jetzt auf einen Job
als Entwickler bewirbst oder dich überhaupt
als Praktikant irgendwo
sowas zu bewerben. Deswegen ist
Outreach-Programme, ich weiß,
dass andere Open-Source-Projekte
auch haben,
schon extrem nützlich, weil Leute,
sehr viele Leute, gerade aus diesen
unterrepräsentierten Gruppen,
genauso gut sind,
wie aber häufig
durch gesellschaftlichen
Zwang oder Unsicherheit,
persönliche Unsicherheit, dann wahrscheinlich
vielleicht sich nicht getraut hätten,
solche Jobs oder solche Aufgaben
anzunehmen. Deswegen ist es ziemlich geil.
Gerade wenn man halt sieht bei Mozilla
oder andere große Firmen, wenn man sich
bewirbt, wo man wirklich nicht weiß, okay,
bin ich dafür wirklich geeignet.
Und hier ist einfach
auch gleiche Länge wie Google Summer of Code.
Man weiß halt, es sind nur diese
drei Monate, glaube ich,
an denen ich da anarbeite.
Und dann habe ich halt
quasi das Projekt, muss ich abgeben.
Also wenn man jetzt bei
Mozilla mitarbeiten möchte.
Haben wir jetzt also mehrere
Angriffsvektoren
gefunden. Man kann
sich einfach in
Buxilla oder auf
den Seiten, die wir momentan nicht aus dem Kopf wissen,
aber in den Shownotes verlinken werden.
Die beste Seite für
den Einstieg ist whatcanido.org
Frage nicht,
was Mozilla für dich tun kann.
Okay.
Also die einfachste Variante ist wirklich immer halt zu schauen,
okay, ich habe Interesse, ich möchte daran mitarbeiten,
ich möchte mir erstmal ein bisschen einarbeiten in die Code-Basis
und vielleicht gibt es ja quasi irgendwann halt die Chance
oder das Interesse auch am Outreach, die Projekte mitzumachen
oder Grusam auf Code oder ja.
Bei mir ist halt so gelaufen selber,
ich bin 2000 mit dazugekommen bei Mozilla,
ja per Zufall, das war damals noch die Mozilla Suite,
0.96 mal so ein 2.
Ah ja, da bin ich auch in der Fall eingestiegen.
Bei den 0.8er,
0.9er Versionen.
Gab es noch 0.8er?
Du bist wahrscheinlich bei Firefox jetzt.
Oder bei
bei der Suite.
Bei Phoenix.
Suite, das ist ja schon entsprechend vor 2000
gewesen.
Ich weiß, dass ich irgendwann mal
einen Abend verbracht habe und endlich
Mozilla 1.0 runtergeladen habe.
Und weil ich das gemacht hatte und es so cool fand
und das hat ja Geld gekostet, das runterzuladen,
habe ich das dann auf CD gebrannt
und auf dem Schulhof verteilt.
Ich habe auf dem Schulhof mit Mozilla gedealt.
Okay, cool.
2000 bin ich halt mehr dazugekommen,
der Zufall auch mit
und habe mich dann entsprechend erstmal in den ganzen Newsgroups umgehört,
weil ich selbst halt Fragen hatte,
die ich beantwortet haben wollte,
beruflich auch mit.
und fand das halt entsprechend so cool,
wie die Leute einfach reagiert haben, so schnell
und wirklich so
sozial-kollegial in deutscher Form
auch mit, dass ich selber angefangen habe,
dann entsprechend da
in den Newsgroups mit Fragen zu beantworten,
wenn Leute Probleme hatten.
Das lief ungefähr zwei Jahre,
bis ich dann von
einem Mozilla-Angestellten
gefragt worden bin, ob ich denn gerne an einer
Lokalisierung mithelfen möchte.
War damals das Projekt Mozilla Europe
gestartet worden, das heißt
die erste europäische Präsenz von Mozilla
auch mit, wo die Webseite quasi
dann auf Deutsch übersetzt werden musste.
Und da wurde ich halt
gefragt, ob ich es gerade machen möchte, habe ein Ja gesagt,
gab es dann die erste Übersetzung auf Deutsch
auch mit von Mozilla.org
Mozilla-Europe.org
Genau.
Die gibt es jetzt auch schon lange nicht mehr.
Im Internet Archive
hast du vielleicht noch eine Chance,
die zu finden.
Das heißt, es war das zweite Projekt
und anschließend
bin ich dann eigentlich direkt in QA
mitgelandet und habe da
wirklich fast jeden Tag ein bis zwei Stunden
freiwillig da mitgeholfen.
In QA.
Hat dann nach einer Weile auch schon meine ersten Projekte
bekommen.
Was hast du damals gemacht?
Hast du auch schon Testautomatisierung
gebaut? Beruflich?
Nein, als QA.
Da war
mit Testautomatisierung am Anfang nichts gewesen.
Das ging erst am Ende los.
genau. Und
das war eher mehr
Bereich, war ein neues Feature.
Bestelle mal den Testplan. Wir wollen einfach mal schauen,
wie du das machst. Mach mal eine Checkliste
oder wie. Genau. Was muss
getestet werden? Ja, so hat man das gemacht
in den Frühjahr 2000.
Das war dann schon so 2005,
2006 gewesen. Genau.
Und
dann wurde halt geschaut, wie mache
ich es halt in dem Sinne. Und
das lief eigentlich relativ gut dann damals.
und deswegen ging ich halt durch mehrere Projekte
halt mit durch und bis ich
irgendwann so selber
brauche ich eine Veränderung,
ich versuche es mal bei Mozilla zu bewerben
und vielleicht klappt es ja.
Aber du hast ja schon
längst bei Mozilla gearbeitet zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Freiwillig halt, aber ist immer
was anderes halt als besser angestellt.
Krass, das war dann 2009 seitdem?
Das war 2009. Seitdem bist du
fester Mosirien. Genau.
Ja. Und was ich noch vergessen hatte,
ist gerade bei den freiwilligen Helfern
gibt es natürlich auch dann gewisse Rewards,
die wir halt mit verteilen,
für die Hilfe, die sie auch mitmachen.
Sticker.
Wenn du auf Meetups dabei bist,
da gibt es immer Sticker, genau.
Wenn der Laptop-Screen noch nicht voll genug ist,
findet sich immer noch einen Platz.
Aber gerade für diejenigen, die wirklich sehr aktiv sind,
wollen wir natürlich auch mitbelohnen.
Das heißt, wir haben momentan zweimal im Jahr
All Hands Treffen, die
verteilt auf der ganzen Welt
mit stattfinden, vorrangig momentan Amerika,
wo diese
100 aktivsten Personen auch mit
eingeladen werden zum Beispiel.
Das heißt, man ist hier wirklich eine ganze Woche, man bekommt
Flug, Unterkunft, Essen,
alles gesponsert, ist eine
ganze Woche mit uns halt zusammen und
sieht einfach, wie
wir halt arbeiten. Man kann mitarbeiten,
kann mitdiskutieren an den verschiedenen Projekten.
Das letzte war irgendwie in San Francisco?
Das letzte Mal San Francisco, genau.
Kann so eine Woche von Mozilla
nach San Francisco geschickt werden?
Ich bin hier gerade mal
auf whatcanidoformazilla.org
und das
scheint nur eine randomized
Seite zu sein.
What's your
area of expertise? User experience
design.
Tell me more
oder jetzt sind hier zwei Buttons. Tell me more
oder show me something else.
Advocacy.
Das machst du ja hier quasi schon.
Tell me more oder boring.
Teaching.
Next, please.
User support.
Ich klicke einfach mal durch.
Dann kriegt man hier Testing Software.
Writing code.
Ah, das klingt gut.
Tell me more.
So, und dann.
What's your favorite programming language?
PHP.
Show me something else.
Achso, jetzt bin ich ein Level drin.
Jetzt gibt es noch ein Button mehr.
I was wrong.
Take me back.
Java.
That's not my line of expertise.
Python, show me something else
C, yeah, next please
Rusty, oh yeah, tell me more
So, you like thinking hard
about ownership and lifetimes, that's cool
We're all masochists at heart
You could work on
Servo, a new web browser
Okay, show me something else
Rusty, the compiler
Not interested, Servo
Next please, Rusty
Also okay, ich habe
das Ende des Bombs erreicht
okay, Rusty, tell me more.
Und jetzt lande ich auf einer
GitHub-Seite,
der Contributing-MD von
dem Rust-Compiler.
Es kommt immer darauf an,
welche Sektion du dich befindest,
welche SAP-Sektion.
Haben wir entweder Wiki-Seiten,
wo halt beschrieben wird,
wo du halt mehr Informationen bekommst,
oder halt direkt halt wie bei Server
oder bei Rusty, dann die GitHub-Contributing-Seite.
Ich mache ja mal Backtracking.
Also, I was wrong, take me back.
So, what's your favorite programming language?
Bin ich jetzt auf dem Level?
I was wrong, take me back.
Weiter nach oben.
What's your area of expertise?
Writing code?
Sind wir gerade an, nee, boring.
Translation?
No, not interested.
User experience design.
Ach, das klingt gut.
Tell me more.
Und jetzt gibt's hier Mozilla Creative.
Ach, jetzt gibt's hier schon nur noch das.
So, you enjoy designing new ways for users to interact with applications and websites.
You could work on Mozilla Creative.
Wenn ich jetzt hier draufklicke, sehe ich schon, ich lande auf der nächsten GitHub-Seite,
nämlich github.com slash mozilla open design.
Ah ja, abgefahren.
Das Tool finde ich tatsächlich ganz cool.
Das wäre wirklich ein guter Einstieg.
Wenn man jetzt nicht weiß, an was möchte ich arbeiten,
überhaupt nicht weiß,
dass man sich hier wirklich einfach erstmal runterhangeln kann
und schauen kann, okay, was bieten wir an, wo kann ich überhaupt mithelfen.
Also nachdem ich die Bewerbungsunterlagen, die Career-Unterseiten,
Unterseiten von
einigen Firmen mir angeguckt habe, ist das
tatsächlich ein sehr spielerischer Einstieg, um so
ein Thema für... Ich finde,
da können sich einige ein Beispiel dran nehmen.
Also gerade für das Contributing
ist es nicht wirklich nur, ich möchte dir
jetzt Code beisteuern.
Das ist doch das Einzige, was ich kann.
Du machst doch auch Advocacy, oder?
Zumindest mit Trust.
Ja, ich rede ja eigentlich hauptsächlich
über das, was mich persönlich interessiert.
Genau, aber wenn man
als Mozilla Rap
Mozilla Repräsentant
gibt es wirklich weltweit in jedem Land
gibt es Leute, die wirklich
erklären, was wir machen
Projekte auch mit durchführen
etc. kann man sich anmelden
Das heißt, das wäre eine andere
Alternative auch mit, wer wirklich es nicht coden möchte
oder andere technische Sachen nicht
machen möchte
viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten
auch mit. Und wenn man überhaupt nichts weiß
stehe ich auch sehr gerne zur Verfügung,
mal die ersten Hinweise zu geben.
Einfach mich kontaktieren.
Ja, also
da habt ihr es gehört. Ja, also
sieht zumindest ziemlich schick aus, diese Seite.
Du wirst
jetzt demnächst weitere
Meetups in Dresden zum Thema
Firefox und Nutella
organisieren. Ich denke mal,
ich möchte sehr gerne halt, dass mehr Leute
auch mitkommen. Sehr gerne sehen.
Also unser Meetup ist auch,
je nachdem, was für ein Thema wir ausgeschrieben
unterschiedlich besucht gewesen.
Ich weiß, das Bestbesuchte war das, was wir zum
Thema Webentwicklung mit Rust
in Rocket gemacht hatten.
Und das Letzte, was wir gemacht hatten, da hatten
wir den Florian Gilcher zu Besuch, der ja dann
an dem gleichen Wochenende hier auch eine Folge
akronomisiert bei mir drauf genommen hatte. Da hat irgendwie
die Werbung überhaupt nicht funktioniert und es waren glaube ich
fünf Leute da. Was ja sehr
spannend war, ich war nämlich den einen Abend vorher
in Berlin bei dem Rust-Beat-Up, da waren
60 Leute da.
Dresden ist irgendwie ein ganz schön anderes
Pflaster als so in Berlin.
aber ja
genau, du hast hier noch einen anderen Link
genau, das heißt für diejenigen, die sich wirklich
interessieren, Code mit beizustören
gibt es halt noch die Webseite
codetribute.mozilla.org
das ist kein Typo?
nee
da kommen wir entsprechend auch dabei, so was ich vor uns halt meinte
das heißt hier kann man wirklich auswählen
ey, ich hab Interesse
JavaScript zu machen oder Python, Rust
wählen wir entsprechend
die Sprache aus, dann sieht man
hat hier eine Liste von verschiedenen
Projekten und
bekommt entsprechend dann für das Projekt
die Liste
von Bugtickets angezeigt.
Gleich eins ausgesucht, wo nichts drin war. Ah ja, hier.
addons.mozilla.org
Das ist jetzt quasi einfach bloß
eine andere Ansicht auf Bugzilla oder
was sehe ich hier?
Auf Bugzilla
taggen wir entsprechend die Bugs als Mentor
und als easy,
als einfach, schwer, etc.
Das heißt hier, diese
Webseite benutzt einfach die
Bugseller-API, um entsprechend diese
Bugs zu extrahieren
und ein bisschen visuell, grafisch
aufgemotzt entsprechend auch mit darzustellen,
um die Sache
einfacher zu finden. Aber hier sind tatsächlich auch
Sachen drin, die ich sonst eigentlich eher von GitHub kenne.
Also hier ist wirklich auch Cargo und
der Rust-Linter-Clippy dabei.
Ich denke mal,
das Server muss ja auch mit dir drin sein.
Das heißt, wenn man
entsprechend auf diese Kategorien drauf geht,
landet man entsprechend auch auf den
eher so GitHub-Sachen.
Dann werden die GitHub-Issues quasi mit reingezogen, genau.
Cool.
Ja, das packen wir einfach alles
mit in die Show Notes, weil
finanziell kann man viel. Schaut es euch einfach mal an,
wenn ihr Interesse habt,
an Mozilla-Projekten
mitzuarbeiten.
Genau.
Ich sehe
ja auch SUL dabei, also
XUL. Das ist doch abgeschafft worden, oder?
Ist noch nicht ganz abgeschafft.
Wir arbeiten momentan daran,
das zu entfernen.
Kannst du mir ein bisschen was über den aktuellen Zustand
erzählen? Soweit ich weiß,
ja. Das heißt
XUL, Extensible User
Markup Language, was damals auch
schon in der Mozilla Suite genutzt wurde.
Das ist sogar schon.
Also Anfang der 2000er war ja XML
en vogue und da hat das
Mozilla genommen, um darin
seine User Interfaces für eine Cross-Platform-Browser
UI
zu schreiben, richtig?
Das ist ein XML-Dialekt.
Genau, und der ist allerdings mittlerweile überholt,
weil man mittlerweile komplette Browser auch rein in HTML bauen kann, richtig?
Mit HTML5 und Web Components hat man natürlich jetzt die Möglichkeit,
all diese Elemente abzubilden, auch in HTML.
Das heißt, Xul wird jetzt nicht mehr benötigt.
Das ist natürlich ein großes Overhead, was wir loswerden möchten,
was auch entsprechend viel Vorarbeit gebraucht hat.
Viele Benutzer waren entsprechend auch enttäuscht,
dass zum Beispiel die Legacy-Extensions
nicht mehr verwendet werden können,
sondern die Web-Extension-API.
Stimmt, es gab vor mit 57
diesen großen Bruch,
wo ganz viele Add-ons für Mozilla
plötzlich nicht mehr supportet wurden.
Also gerade die Legacy-Extensions,
die vorwiegend mit Overlays gearbeitet haben
auf School-Basis,
mussten wir leider alle abschaffen
in dem Sinne,
auch aufgrund Elektrolysis
mehr Prozesse
in Firefox, Rust-Implementierung
und so weiter, war
natürlich alles notwendig gewesen. Rust ist schuld.
Okay, ja.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich
auch ganz gut, weil man
das Problem an Software
im Gegensatz zu Maschinen,
die gebaut werden, Autos, Häuser,
ist, dass sie von alleine nicht verrotten.
Gehen nicht kaputt, es ist gut.
Auf der anderen Seite
hat man in vielen Projekten so
Code rumliegen,
der zwar irgendwie noch funktioniert,
aber den eigentlich seit Jahren keiner mehr kennt oder angeguckt hat
oder der nicht anständig mitwächst mit den Anforderungen.
Deswegen ist es doch eigentlich ganz gut,
wenn man ab und zu mal Sachen deprecated und komplett abschafft.
Genau.
Das heißt, hier arbeiten wirklich sehr viele Entwickler auch daran,
die ganzen Code zu entfernen,
entsprechend umzuschreiben in HTML, Web Components.
Wir haben schon sehr viele Bindings entsprechend auch schon wegbekommen.
Ich schätze mal gleich die Hälfte ungefähr.
Das heißt, es ist immer noch sehr viel Arbeit notwendig,
bis man wirklich komplett auf HTML-Oberfläche umsteigen kann.
Und das hätte dann den Vorteil, dass man aus Gecko, aus der Rederang-Engine,
einfach einen ganzen Schlagcode, der für das Verarbeiten von SUE verantwortlich ist, rausschmeißen kann.
Übrigens hat das auch ein Grund, warum der RSS-Ried rausgeflogen ist.
Das ist allerdings überaustausch.
Da hattest du dich halt auch, dann habe ich mitbekommen.
Ich warst ja nicht sehr froh darüber gewesen.
Ja, aber RSS ist ja leider auch so ein Format,
was nie so richtig sein Potenzial ausgeschöpft hat, muss ich sagen.
Also ich betreibe selber so ein privates Tiny-Tiny RSS.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool, wenn man unterschiedliche Seiten aggregieren kann
und sich die dann bei sich zu Feeds zusammenstellen kann
und dann aus dem Ding wieder raus
eigene Feeds exportieren kann,
sodass man quasi wie so ein soziales
Blogosphere-Network
Nachrichten miteinander teilen könnte.
Aber wenn das sonst auch kaum jemand macht,
dann ist es halt nicht mächtig.
Und woran es dann immer auch gekrankt hat,
ist die Anzahl der Applikationen,
die damit arbeiten können.
Heute gibt es nur so eine Nachfolge davon,
das wäre sowas wie Pocket oder so.
diesen Spirit so ein bisschen nachahmt,
wo man sagt, ich abonniere was und ich kann
das weiterempfehlen, aber
eigentlich diese, wir machen das
auf Basis von Standardtechnologien,
dieser Ansatz, hat an dieser Stelle
leider nicht gefruchtet, was schade
ist. Also ich nutze
es noch exzessiv, versuche
es auch, gerade
in Newsseiten, die ich lese, entsprechend auch
die ASS-Feed zu bekommen, was mittlerweile
auch teilweise schon schwierig ist.
Das heißt, wenn mal eine... Das ist auch nicht unbedingt
im Interesse dieser News-Seiten, weil die
kriegen ja ihre Werbung über RSS nicht verteilt.
Genau, richtig. Oder man muss sich anmelden
und dann wird quasi
bloß noch eine Einleitung quasi
im RSS-Feed geteilt, aber man hat
nicht mehr den Zug auf den gesamten Artikel.
Das heißt,
für mich wird es schon schwieriger
quasi RSS-Feeds
zu bekommen. Was für eine Software benutzt du
zum Lesen von RSS-Feeds? Also ich lese
meine eigentlich nur noch auf dem Handy.
Da nutze ich den G-Reader,
der leider halt nicht mehr supportet.
Ja, es ist halt, ne?
Leider auch closed doors.
Das heißt, niemand weiß entsprechend,
was mit dem Auto passiert.
Der meldet sich auch nicht.
Ist unresponsive, schon über ein Jahr.
Aber ist immer noch der beste Reader für mich.
Das heißt,
als Zwischending läuft noch Feedly.
Gerade wenn man dann doch
ein paar Tage kein Netz hat,
was man passieren kann,
wenn man unterwegs ist.
Dass man halt keine News verpasst.
Also mein Tiny Tiny RSS benutzen
ein, zwei Leute aus meinem Freundeskreis mit.
Ich persönlich
habe schon lange nicht mehr reingeguckt, muss ich sagen.
Aber vielleicht
kann man ja auch was Neues bauen.
Aber da kommt, glaube ich, ganz schön weit ab vom Thema jetzt.
Ja, du hast
die Sorge gemacht, dass wir keine Stunde vollkriegen.
Ich habe es nur ganz kurz erwähnt gehabt
mit RSS.
Das ist ein Feature, wie gesagt,
was Unmaintained ist bei uns,
woran keiner arbeiten wird.
Und deswegen müssen die Sachen einfach auch
rausfliegen halt leider.
Ja, man kann so eine
Technologie nicht ewig weiterverwenden, wenn sie
sich nicht durchsetzt oder nicht,
es muss ja eine
Nachfrage danach bestehen und wenn es offenbar
nicht da ist. Die Nachfrage ist schon da.
Deswegen wurde auch dann
Web-Extension halt geschrieben, wo es
möglich dieses Feature mit implementiert
wieder. Ach so? Also gerade, ich glaube,
selbst Live-Bookmarks müssten dann schon wieder
funktionieren. Abgefahren.
Das ist cool.
Ja, also vielen Dank für
Einblick. Wir haben eine Sektion,
die Kea noch nicht immer befüllen,
und das sind die GitHub-Stars
der Woche.
Das muss nicht unbedingt ein GitHub-Star sein,
das kann auch ein
Bugzilla-
Lieblings-Bug sein, oder
ein bestimmtes Tool, was du, ich meine,
du und ich entwickeln
Software mit, wie ich festgestellt habe,
sehr unterschiedlichen Werkzeugen.
Schon allein die Tatsache, dass du Mercurial
auf Arbeit benutzt.
Was sind so coole Projekte oder Tools,
die du so empfehlen könntest?
Also mit denen ich dann
tagtäglich im Bereich
zu arbeiten habe,
gerade im Bereich
Gecko-Triber, der auch in RAS
geschrieben ist.
Das war jetzt mein Einstiegspunkt
auch gewesen für die RAS-Programmiersprache,
weswegen wir uns auch quasi kennengelernt haben.
Wir haben ja schon mal zusammen drauf geguckt.
Genau, richtig.
Und da war ja eines meiner großen Projekte gewesen,
die Umwandlung des Codes
Serialize in SIRDI
ist einfach ein geniales Projekt.
Das wäre das der Wahnsinn auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt, hat diese
automatisierte Umwandlung
von den Datenstrukturen
in das JSON und
die Serialisierung und die Deserialisierung
ist genial, hat
entsprechend auch wahnsinnig viel Arbeit für mich gemacht
an dem ganzen Projekt, das entsprechend
mit einem Mal umzusetzen.
Weil vorher war die, also
mal als kurzer Einstieg,
Serial...
Der Gekko-Driver
redet mit Marinette im Browser
über ein Protokoll
und das sind JSON-Nachrichten, die ausgetauscht
werden, richtig? Das sind auch JSON-Nachrichten.
Genau, und die ursprüngliche Implementierung
hat ein Framework benutzt, was halt
im Rust-Compiler für
Serialisierung benutzt wurde, nämlich Rust-C
Serialize, ist allerdings schon seit
einiger Zeit in
Rust selber
mehr oder weniger deprecated und
man soll lieber
SIRDE nehmen, weil man bei SIRDE
über Annotationen
und Procedural Macros
einfach durch
dieses Derive
Keyword am
einzelnen Structs oder Inams
Structs oder Inams
Serialisierungscode erzeugen kann,
der das auch noch ziemlich effizient
für beliebige Serialisierungsformate,
also nicht nur JSON, sondern auch
YAML oder Messagepack
oder so was ich, erzeugt.
Und das habt ihr
quasi alles nochmal, das war ursprünglich
mit Rusty Serialize Hand geklöppelt,
wo ihr so Two-JSON-Methoden
für jedes Ding selber geschrieben hattet.
Jede Menge.
Genau, und jetzt musstet ihr aber nur noch das
Format
quasi in Rust-Tatentypen dann
austauschen und
dort Serialize, Deserialize ranschreiben.
Einfach gesagt, ja, bei vielen Sachen
ist natürlich nicht machbar,
unseren Bereich einfach nur Serialized,
Deserialized zu verwenden.
Man muss wirklich dann auch selbst
Serialized, Deserialized
implementieren, weil einfach die Struktur
komplexer ist und
bei Default kann man das nicht selber auflösen.
Weil natürlich
dein Code zu einem
recht normalisierten
Format generiert werden würde, was
allerdings, wenn so spezielle
Quarks in zum Beispiel im JSON-Format bereits
existieren, dann
nicht exakt dieses Format ausspucken würde.
Ich habe das selber neulich mal,
da wollte ich vielleicht noch ein Blogpost drüber schreiben,
gemacht,
um das Format für
die Web-API
der DVB nochmal
mit Serda abzubilden
und mit Requests einfach so.
Es hat super Spaß gemacht, das kann ich eigentlich
nur empfehlen, das mal zu machen, so Web-APIs
mit Serda und Requests abbauen,
wo du einfach sagst, hier, mach mal
diese Abfrage und schmeiß mir
dass man diesen Datentypen und es serialisiert es da rein.
Und da waren auch so Sachen drin wie,
es fängt an bei
Rust Properties von
Struct sind alle im Snake Case
geschrieben.
Bei JSON-Datenstrukturen sind die
Properties CamelCase.
Nun würde der
Serta in seiner Default-Konfiguration
auch Snake Case produzieren.
Und du musst dir jetzt reinschreiben, mach mal CamelCase.
Und bei dieser API
von der DVB waren die
Properties nicht CamelCased, sondern
Pascal Case.
Und dann schreibst du nicht
dieses Attribut Camel Case ran, sondern
du schreibst Pascal Case dran.
Und da dachte ich erstmal, warum gibt es nichts?
Es kompiliert nicht, der kennt Pascal Case nicht.
Ich habe irgendwo mal gelesen, dass es geht.
Und dann schaue ich nochmal in die Doku rein,
da war auch Pascal Case selber nicht so dokumentiert,
sondern nur Camel Case und Snake Case.
Und da fiel mir auf, ah, Camel Case,
vorne kleines C, Mitte, großes C,
Snake Case, vorne kleines S,
Unterstrich, Case.
Ah, das ist selber so geschrieben.
schreibe ich Pascal Case vorne mit einem großen P,
zack geht's.
Ja, es ist wirklich Magie,
was sie heute
entsprechend bereitstellt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Kannst allerdings auch andere Sachen damit machen
irgendwie. Ich hatte dann in diesem
DVB-Beispiel
war eine Liste,
hatte ein Objekt
als Property eine Liste von anderen Sachen,
die allerdings nicht als JSON-Liste
dargestellt war, sondern das war ein String,
der mit unterschiedlichen
Pipes getrennt war.
Und jetzt wollte ich dafür nicht sagen, jetzt mach mir das mal
auf als String und dann passt
das nochmal neu nicht. Ich wollte, dass Serde das schon
in das richtige Format rein serialisiert.
Und dann kannst du das natürlich deinen eigenen
Visitor dafür schreiben und dann sagen,
pack das mal aus.
Und das war bei eurem Format
auch so, dass ihr da einfach
nicht standardkonformes
JSON hattet?
Direkt den Visitor musste ich jetzt nicht schreiben?
war einfach nur
Custom-Code, um halt
die Datentypen
zu kompartieren in spezielle
Formate halt und gerade die
Syntax auch mit
zu checken dann.
Das wirklich auch alles stimmt.
Obwohl ihr habt doch an dieser Stelle eigentlich
ist es, was zwischen Marinet und
Genco-Driver gesprochen wird, ist ein
proprietäres Format.
Das Problem war hier eher der Bereich
die Web-Treiber-Schnittstelle nach außen hin.
Ah, okay. Das ist auch
ein JSON-Format? Das ist auch JSON, genau.
Das ist standardisiert.
Was entsprechend dann von
Gecko-Treiber zu Marinette geht, ist nicht standardisiert.
Das ist einfach ein
Custom-Socket-Protokoll, aber wir schicken
auch hier die JSON-Nachrichten.
Das heißt, das Problem war einfach nur
großteils auf der Seite entsprechend
auch mit nach außen hin,
wo ich quasi alles neu abbilden musste.
Genau.
Ja, ich denke mal.
Krass, also...
Zu dem GitHub-Star.
Ja, also dein GitHub-Star ist Serde?
Ja. Cool. Also schaut euch
wirklich mal Serde an. Ich kann jetzt ein bisschen
zusammenhangslos gewesen sein, was wir jetzt gerade erzählt haben,
weil wir es beide schon sehr intensiv benutzt haben.
Aber wenn es gerade darum geht,
Serialisierungsformate,
unterschiedliche Serialisierungsformate zu unterstützen,
es ist extrem krass, was da möglich
ist. Also mir fällt
immer wieder ein, in JavaScript ist es
super einfach, JSON zu
verarbeiten. Du sagst from JSON to JSON,
Parse, jedes JavaScript-Objekt
ist quasi schon super
serialisierbar nach JSON.
Aber was ist denn, wenn dein Übertragungsformat
nicht JSON ist, sondern irgendwas anderes,
was Arbiträres, was Binäres
vielleicht, ja? Oder wenn du halt
tatsächlich solche Umwandlungsgeschichten
hast, dann baust du, fängst du dein JavaScript
damit an, zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt
trotzdem nach JSON was umwandeln willst, hast du ja
Tonweise für irgendwelche APIs, die du
ansprichst, dann machst du vorher nochmal ein anderes
JavaScript-Objekt raus, was du dann
umwandelst. Bei Serda kannst du wirklich
sagen, mein Datentyp ist der,
das ist so idiomatisch für die Sprache,
das sieht so aus,
und dann schreibst du halt den
Serialisierungscode so, dass das auf die Art und Weise
umwandelt, dass dann trotzdem ein kompatibles,
auch wenn es anders strukturiert ist,
Wire-Format
herauskommt. Das ist ziemlich krass. Wenn ich sehe, wie
bei uns auf Arbeit zum Beispiel
die Umwandlung von
JSON nach C++-Code
gelöst ist,
ist zwar sehr elegant
gemacht, wir haben da so
JSON-Spec-Dateien, aus denen C++-Code
generiert wird und
daraus kannst du auch
TypeScript-Typen generieren,
um das dann auf der anderen Seite
sauber anzubinden, aber es ist trotzdem
nicht nativ zu der Sprache.
Bei Rust geht das absolut super.
Ja, aber sehr cool. Ja, was heißt denn du,
Henrik?
Ich habe ein
Beispiel hier, wo wir
gerade über JSON reden. JSON ist zwar
Nett.
Aber eigentlich ist JSON schon ganz schön scheiße.
Also das eigentliche
Versprechen von JSON, das ist das JavaScript
Object Notation Format.
Er hält es eigentlich selber nicht ein,
weil
JSON ist zwar von der Schreibweise,
wenn du es hinschreibst, valides JavaScript,
aber valides JavaScript
ist nicht JSON.
Das heißt, du musst bei Properties,
die Properties dürfen nur Strings
sein, sie müssen allerdings immer
in Quotes sein.
du kannst keine Kommentare in deinem JSON haben
zumindest nicht in validem JSON
manche drücken sich da drum, indem sie
einen nicht validen JSON-Parser
für ihre Dokumente nehmen
zum Beispiel
TypeScript Conf
JSON-Dateien, also die
Konfigurationsdateien für den TypeScript
Compiler enthalten per
Default Kommentare, ist eigentlich kein valides
JSON, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass sie es nicht mit dem
Standard Node oder Browser
JSON-Parser parsen
deswegen gibt es
andere Formate
YAML war eine Alternative dazu
ist allerdings ein Monster für sich
ist viel zu viel, viel zu groß
kann viel zu viele Sachen, es kann irgendwie
Referenzen auf andere Objekte
in YAML kann jedes Objekt
Key eines anderen Objekts sein
das heißt der Key von einem Objekt
könnte selber
ein Objekt sein, es ist der Horror
es ist viel zu groß
und was ich jetzt als sehr elegante Alternative
gefunden habe, ist
JSON5.
Nicht Jackson5, JSON5.
Und das ist quasi
das Verspricht das gleiche wie JSON,
aber ist von seiner
Syntax her
tatsächlich JavaScript. Das heißt, du kannst da
Properties ohne Quotes machen,
du kannst Trail-In-Commas haben,
wer auch immer das mag,
du kannst Kommentare drin haben,
genau,
du kannst unterschiedliche String-Formate drin haben,
du kannst Typen drin haben,
wie, ich glaube, es geht
sowas wie
Infinite,
was ein valider JavaScript-Typ
ist, aber
halt nicht in JSON ausdrückbar ist.
Genau.
Und das finde ich ziemlich geil.
Es liest sich wie
JavaScript und es
enthält keinen ausführbaren Code,
aber es ist halt ein besseres JSON.
Ziemlich cooles Projekt.
Gibt es nicht für
Serta auch schon
great, mit dem man...
Aber natürlich. Ich hatte erst
geliebäugelt mit
eine andere Variante ist noch
hjson, das ist human json.
Das geht ein bisschen in eine andere Richtung,
da kannst du zum Beispiel, das geht eher in diese
CoffeeScript oder
YAML-Richtung, da kannst du teilweise
die Kommas weglassen und dafür
einfach bei Zeilen und Brüchen kannst du einfach
Listen mit Zeilen und Brüchen statt Kommas machen.
Ist allerdings dann schon wieder
nicht mehr ganz so
klar, also du kannst da wahrscheinlich auch missverständliche
Sache mitmachen. Dafür gab es auch einen
JSON,
eine Quatsch, einen
Serda Serializer, die Serializer.
Der wurde allerdings nie auf
Serda 1.0 geupdatet,
weshalb du
nicht sauber
dann von einem,
also du kannst nicht für
eine Datenstruktur nach
dort serialisieren und
eine andere Datenstruktur, die
Serda 1.0 kompatibel ist,
serialisieren, weil sehr unterschiedliche
Varianten als Dependency hatte.
Das ist eklig. Aber
tatsächlich, wenn man es genauer anguckt, ist
JSON5 auch ein sinnvolleres Format,
weil es wirklich einfach nur
die JavaScript-Syntax ist.
Das ist ziemlich schick. Genau.
Hast du zufällig noch was?
Ich denke mal eins, was
What the fuck Python?
Muss ich das jetzt schneiden?
Es heißt direkt so,
das Projekt aufgeht habe.
WTF-Python?
Hier gibt es einfach sehr, sehr viele Code-Py-Spiele
über
verschiedene
Syntax, wo man
doch denkt, das funktioniert
ganz anders, als man wirklich gedacht hat.
Kann ich nur empfehlen,
sich einfach mal durchzuschauen, also gerade
was ist Operator oder Yielding,
was auch immer auch immer ist,
welche Effekte halt hier teilweise
unerwünscht plötzlich auftauchen könnten,
wenn man Python-Code schreibt.
sowas halten sich ja Leute gerne mal vor die Nase
wenn sie sagen wollen, deine Sprache ist scheiße
muss man sich häufig anhören
als Javascript-Entwickler
von Leuten, die sagen, ja, aber Python ist viel besser
aber es ist gut, dass du mich darauf hinweist, dann kann ich den Leuten, die
das bei mir auf Arbeit machen, sagen, hier, guck mal
Python, what the fuck
cool, was haben wir da alles
mit drin, Strings
can be tricky sometimes
is not
or is not, ach stimmt, das gibt es ja auch
nach, is not, is not, is not
Ja, oh Gott.
Okay, schaut euch das mal an. Wir gehen da ziemlich auf Beispiele ein.
Nice.
Wo wir vorhin von RSS-Readern
geredet haben, ein Beispiel
könnte ich noch nennen.
Und zwar
habe ich mich immer gefragt, wann es auf Basis
von Web-Renderer, der in
Firefox drin ist,
endlich mal ein UI-Framework geben wird,
mit dem man
native Desktop- oder
Mobile-Anwendungen bauen kann.
Und hier gibt es tatsächlich ein Projekt, ich weiß nicht, wie
es ist, aber es sieht schon recht vielversprechend aus.
Das heißt
Azure. Gesundheit.
Und der Name klingt schon so ein bisschen, als ob
es irgendwie an Zool anlehnt,
aber wahrscheinlich hat es damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Es hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Es ist kein
XML-Dialekt. Das ist einfach
ein
auf Webrenderer basierendes, in Rust
geschriebenes UI-Framework. Hier gibt es so ein paar
Beispiele, wo es so Tabellenkalkulationen
und Taschenrechner mitgebaut haben.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall recht schick aus.
Man schreibt vornehmlich Rust.
Es gibt, glaube ich, noch kein
Markup-Format dafür.
Aber es ist schon mal
recht gut dokumentiert. Also wenn ihr
mal native Anwendungen für,
ich glaube, das ist auch Plattformen, wir begreifen, das ist ja schließlich
Web-Renderer im Endeffekt,
bauen wollt, dann schaut euch das mal an.
asul.rs
Genau. So, und bevor du jetzt da drin weiterliest,
würde ich sagen,
haben wir noch was?
Also ich hätte jetzt erstmal nichts mehr.
Nee? Nee.
Henrik, sehr schön, dass du mal bei mir
bei Akronymisierbar zu Gast gewesen bist.
Ich bedanke mich sehr. Ich danke auch.
Es war mir eine helle Freude.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet beim Zuhören auch
ein klein wenig Spaß und
Interesse gefunden an den Themen, die wir hier besprochen haben.
Ich hoffe, wir sehen uns bald wieder, vielleicht auf einem Meetup
hier in Dresden
Auf jeden Fall
Und bis dahin, hört weiter fleißig Podcast
Der nächste Podcast in eurem
Petcatcher beginnt nämlich bereits
in 3, 2, 1